WE WILL SOON FIND OUT IF THAT
HELPS OR HURTS HER STANDING ON
THE LEFT.
>> Chris: THANK YOU.
ONE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TOP
AIDES IS GONE TONIGHT.
THERE ARE GROWING QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF.
STAFF SECRETARY ROB PORTER WHO
YESTERDAY ADMITTED DOMESTIC
ABUSE ALLEGATIONS IS NOW
OFFICIALLY OUT.
TODAY CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS SPOKE
WITH PORTER’S FIRST WIFE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CONFIRMED
STAFF SECRETARY ROB PORTER HAS
LEFT AFTER RESIGNING YESTERDAY,
ADDING THAT THE PRESIDENT FIRST
LEARNED OF THE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST PORTER ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
>> HE WAS SURPRISED.
HE, LIKE MANY OF US, DID NOT SEE
THAT AND ROB PORTER.
ALLEGATIONS HAVE BROUGHT
FORWARD.
HE WAS SURPRISED BY IT,
DISHEARTENED, SADDENED.
>> THAT SPOTLIGHT SHIFTED TO
SENIOR STAFF INCLUDING JOHN
KELLY AND WHEN HE LEARNED OF THE
ALLEGATIONS.
>> HE BECAME FULLY AWARE
YESTERDAY.
NOT GOING TO GET INTO SPECIFICS
REGARDING WHO MAY HAVE KNOWN
WHAT PIECES OF INFORMATION
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL PART OF AN
ONGOING BACKGROUND CHECK
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK WE ALL BECAME AWARE OF
THE NEWS REPORTS THAT EMERGED
WEDNESDAY MORNING AND SOME OF
THE GRAPHIC IMAGES.
>> Reporter: DID HE KNOW ANY
OF THIS IN NOVEMBER?
>> NOT GOING TO GET INTO
SPECIFICS.
>> NOT GOING TO SAY WHEN KELLY
OR OTHER STAFF BECAME AWARE OF
THE ALLEGATIONS BUT COLBIE
HOLDERNESS TOLD FOX NEWS SHE
SPOKE TO THE FBI VOTED ON
JANUARY 25, 2017, MORE THAN A
YEAR AGO.
AS PART OF A SECURITY CLEARANCE
INVESTIGATION, SHE TOLD THE FBI
ABOUT SEVERAL INCIDENTS OF
ABUSE, INCLUDING VACATION IN
FLORENCE, ITALY, WHERE SHE SAYS
PORTER PUNCHED HER IN THE EYE.
PORTER’S SECOND WIFE, JENNIFER
WILLOUGHBY, SAID SHE SPOKE TO
THE FBI.
>> I TOLD THEM THE DETAILS OF MY
MARRIAGE, INCLUDING VERBAL AND
EMOTIONAL ABUSE AND INCLUDING AN
INCIDENT WHEN HE PULLED ME OUT
OF THE SHOWER.
THEY WERE MADE AWARE OF THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER I SIGNED IN
JUNE OF 2010.
THEY WERE MADE AWARE OF ANOTHER
TIME WHEN I HAD CALLED THE
POLICE TO OUR HOME AFTER A
DOMESTIC DISTURBANCE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE REPEATED
PORTER’S DENIALS.
SAID HE WAS NOT DENIED A
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
>> HIS BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION
WAS ONGOING.
HE WAS OPERATING ON AN INTERIM
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
HIS CLEARANCE WAS NEVER DENIED
AND HE RESIGNED.
>> COLBIE HOLDERNESS TOLD
FOX NEWS SHE HAD WARNED THE FBI
PORTER COULD BE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
BLACKMAIL BECAUSE OF HIS
HISTORY.
THE FACT THAT HE WAS BETTING
MOST OF THE DOCUMENTS THAT
LANDED ON THE PRESIDENT’S DESK
WITHOUT A FULL SECURITY
CLEARANCE RAISED EYEBROWS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> OPERATING A YEAR WITHOUT A
SECURITY CLEARANCE, I DIDN’T
UNDERSTAND THAT AND I STILL
DON’T.
WHAT GENERAL KELLY KNEW AND WHEN
HE KNEW IT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE WON’T SAY
WHEN CHIEF OF STAFF CALLIE FIRST
LEARNED OF THE ALLEGATIONS,
THERE WAS A DRAMATIC SHIFT
BETWEEN WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON AND
WEDNESDAY NIGHT.
IN THE AFTERNOON, KELLY PRAISED
PORTER, SAYING "ROB PORTER IS A
MAN OF TRUE INTEGRITY AND HONOR.
I CAN’T SAY ENOUGH GOOD THINGS
ABOUT HIM.
HE IS A FRIEND, A CONFIDANT, AND
TRUSTED PROFESSIONAL.
I AM PROUD TO SERVE ALONGSIDE
HIM."
THAT STATEMENT WAS CRAFTED BY A
NUMBER OF WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
INCLUDING COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR HOPE HICKS WHO IS
ROMANTICALLY INVOLVED WITH
PORTER.
AFTER THE PHOTOS OF A BRUISED
AND BATTERED COLBIE HOLDERNESS
WENT PUBLIC, CHIEF OF STAFF DID
A QUICK ABOUT-FACE, SAYING "I
WAS SHOCKED BY THE NEW
ALLEGATIONS RELEASED TODAY
AGAINST PORTER.
THERE IS NO PLACE FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN OUR
SOCIETY.
I STAND BY MY PREVIOUS COMMENTS
OF THE ROB PORTER THAT I HAVE
COME TO KNOW SINCE BECOMING
CHIEF OF STAFF AND BELIEVE EVERY
INDIVIDUAL DESERVES THE RIGHT TO
DEFEND THEIR REPUTATION."
THE WHITE HOUSE INSISTS IT TAKES
ALLEGATIONS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
SERIOUSLY AND ACKNOWLEDGES
WHITE HOUSE STAFF COULD HAVE
DONE A BETTER JOB IN RESPONDING
TO THE REVELATIONS.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY RAJ
SHAH SAID HOPE HICKS RECUSED